buscan un nuevo record guinness en
venezuela unos 12.000 músicos del
sistema nacional de orquestas juveniles
e infantiles
interpretaron durante 5 minutos la
marcha eslava de tchaikovsky
[Música]
hemos visto generalmente aquí en
venezuela pero
fue algo especial para el espectacular
eufórico estaba muy ansiosa fuerte bueno
es un reto gigantesco por supuesto un
reto muy muy muy complicado pero lleno
de muchísimo orgullo de muchísima pasión
y cuando tú ves aquí a esta cantidad de
niños niñas y jóvenes que nos acompañan
de cada rincón del país de cada estado
sin duda es algo maravilloso es ver el
resultado del sueño del maestro abreu
el fallecido de aclamado músico
venezolano josé antonio abreu fundó el
sistema un programa de educación musical
una red de 180 orquestas en los 350.000
jóvenes y niños
el récord actual lo tiene una orquesta
rusa que con ocho mil noventa y siete
músicos logró la hazaña de san
petersburgo rusia en 2019 quienes tiene
10 días para anunciar si los jóvenes
venezolanos rompieron un nuevo récord